antoinette NEMA ruta is finally getting
treatment at the hospital in kabul she's
been suffering for days from headaches
and stomach cramps her village some 40
kilometers away has just one clinic and
no doctor here at the hospital she can
get a proper examination and undergo
tests she would probably not have been
treated today if she hadn't been signed
up to the country's public health
insurance scheme health insurance is
very important because it gives us
access to medical treatment
without coverage treatment becomes
expensive people can't afford to pay
doctor's bills on their own we've that
access to health care has been enhanced
by the arrival of new ambulances across
Rwanda and the decentralized system
gives doctors at the hospital more time
for their patients minor ailments can be
treated at one of the 200 or so rural
health care centers serving villages
sexy men each facility also has a doctor
present once a week to see the most
serious cases Santi Santi
Antoinette's treatment today will cost
her the equivalent of 20 Euro cents the
rest is covered by the Insurance Program
she also has to pay 10 percent of the
cost of her medication it feels like
down a scalpel no scrap we want to see
more hospitals built that way patients
don't have to travel such long distances
to see a doctor there are only a few
people like me who can afford to buy a
bus ticket for the journey the hospital
in Shibuya is one of more than 40 in the
country as a whole
Rwanda has one doctor for every 18
thousand inhabitants many patients face
a long trip just to reach a doctor once
there however treatment is available and
affordable the overall situation has
improved the changes to the health
insurance system mean that people can
get treatment when they're sick instead
of staying at home that has made a big
difference over the last five years
Rwanda has enjoyed rapid economic growth
in recent years parts of the health care
system are now financed by state funding
plus revenue from health insurance the
Minister of Health
Agnes bina Graha says health care
services are now being used by more than
80% of those insured we have made
progress people have more uptake of
Health Services and of tools innovative
- we are providing them like
vaccinations etc family planning but we
still have a long way to go and me I'm
prefer to focus on what we didn't
achieve than to focus on what we have
achieved because we still have a long
way to go
ruined clavo in eastern Rwanda is a case
in point the local hospital is now less
dependent on foreign aid the American
NGO partners in health help to build the
facility the wards capacity has
increased to 110 in patients but most of
the work here is now taken care of by
Rwandan doctors Partners in Health still
sends regular donations however to
ensure ongoing improvements to the
system to help the population bringing
healthcare and also social support even
the community they support them to be
much financially capable because some
patient with poor but they try to help
them to sustain the economy by some
support them in areas that they would
like for us to be able to support as we
discuss the medical education is one of
the area of need and for the time being
really supporting in terms of building
the capacity of the health professionals
is an area that is key the dividends
from that International Cooperation are
visible on the ground and in the
statistics infant mortality and
childbirth related complications are
declining plus the proportion of
children surviving their fifth birthday
is increasing for people are not paying
and they're receiving subsidized
saboteurs help I think the government
still has a lot of responsibility to be
able to provide to that because it's
actually a lot of people but I think
they meet well system is building up
itself to be a strong and sort of
autonomous entity back to Kabul on the
shores of Lake Eva the government
recently spent about half a million
euros on this water ambulance we have a
plan what we are going to do what we are
going to do next year etc so up to the
time we take over and for the time being
we take over because the aid decrease
last two years the EDF decree
but we have increased the quantity of
care we are giving so it's another way
to take over and like we have recruited
more than 1,000 nos the last two years
more than 200 doctors with our money
the plan also includes making sure that
patients in less accessible areas such
as Lake ki-woo can be picked up by the
aquatic ambulance
you